as concerns grow over the new coven
variant data shows arkansas is among the
bottom 10 states and vaccination rates
just over 49 percent of residents fully
vaccinated governor asa hutchinson is
urging everyone to get their shots but
he says enforcing a mandate is not the
answer governor hutchinson joins us now
what do you know about
the
new variant have you heard anything from
the federal government on what you as a
governor should be considering
we're still waiting for more information
but clearly we're used to dealing with
new variants we had the delta variant
hit us very hard
here in arkansas we're one of the first
states and from what we see in the early
information the omicron variant
might be more contagious but there's not
any indication that it is is as severe
as even the delta variant we're waiting
on more information but in the meantime
we're taking advantage of this to
increase our vaccinations in arkansas
and continue to push those
and we should not be
unsteady in this environment we just
need to wait for more information not
panic
our emergency in arkansas ended
some time ago we're managing the
chronovirus here schools are open
business is open and we want to be able
to continue in that fashion and handle
any new variant that comes in with
increased
vaccination rates i think one of the
things you'll hear from the president
today at 11 45 he'll be speaking about
the new variant and other uh issues
regards to kovid
they believe that mandates have worked
if they look they say look at the
federal government the federal
government mandate for workers as they
are up in the mid 90s in terms of
take-up rates for vaccines but you think
that the mandate for you has actually
made it more difficult to convince
people to get the vaccine
i i do
people
buck up they offer more resistance if
the government's telling this is what
you have to do we're making great
progress through
medical information trusted advisors i
had community town hall meetings and we
gradually increased those vaccination
rate we continue to do it but it's
harder whenever you have the debate
about
the the mandates and so we oppose the
federal mandate this first time in
history they've had this heavy
federal government come in and tell the
states what to do every state might be
different for arkansas
we're using education common sense and
driving those numbers up and people take
it seriously
whenever you see the risk
that increases our vaccination rate and
i think the omicron variant is just
another warning let's get this done and
let's don't delay hi i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now